[Music]
[Music]
unknown participant is now exiting you
think after 20 of these picks you can
figure this out rick what are you
talking about just wait till the little
computer says he's in the room
mike zimmer vikings coach giving gene
rick's batman a little bit of the
business via zoom that's kind of
zimmer's way uh that great stone
fireplace cannot hide money i love that
thing and i don't know how warm or cold
it was in kentucky but even if it was 85
degrees you got to have a fire raging in
that fireplace which he did all right
the most intriguing draft picks for 2020
three-man weave that means we gotta have
nine names ready to go peter gets the
trivia question peter gets the first
pick if he gets it right peter since two
thousand
four nfl teams have not selected a
quarterback in the first round of the
draft four teams have not taken a
quarterback in round one name two of
those teams
new england
and uh
uh
new england and
san francisco
and
new
orleans new orleans the seattle seahawks
and the dallas cowboys have not taken a
quarterback in round one since 2000. and
i tripped it down from three they wanted
you to have to name three of the four
are you kidding me it's hard enough to
think of one i'm awful at these things
anyway it's hard when that when that
clock's ticking when that red light's on
it's hard to process your thoughts all
right chris you got the first pick
okay
like full transparency here i'm sick of
talking about jordan love i'm sick of
talking about tua and i'm sick of
talking about jalen hurts i'm not
picking them just so everybody knows
they're not so you guys can pick them
that's fine i'm not judging or anything
like that i just know i'm picking it up
either
good i've been talking about it for five
days i've had enough okay so that's i'm
not picking him i'm gonna go with isaiah
simmons as one of the most intriguing
picks to me in the whole nfl draft you
know he was one of those guys the
arizona cardinals uh uh picked a what i
call and i said this to isaiah simmons
when i did an interview i call him a
praying mantis with muscles i mean
that's what he is out there in the
football field he's one of those guys
you just you turn on the film and you go
whoa who's that guy he looks really cool
and different and faster and longer than
everybody else and i i give the arizona
cardinals a lot of credit here you know
i think isaiah simmons is one of those
guys that was way too over analyzed
through this draft process where it's
like whoa he didn't play one position
i'd like to see him listen put the guy
five yards off the ball from the line of
scrimmage and let him go run down the
ball carrier it's not complicated he's a
freaky athlete he's physical he of
course can run sideline to sidelines he
can cover that way he's different than
anything we've ever seen really at the
linebacker position this is a special
you know new breed of the nfl and i'm
intrigued to see how they use them and
of course how successful he can be on
that arizona defense
all right peter you're up
i'll take jk dobbins the 55th pick in
this draft by the baltimore ravens and
i'll take him because
so four years ago ezekiel elliott was
the fourth pick in the nfl draft
jk dobbins this year the 55th pick in
the nfl draft in their last years at
ohio state comparing him jk dobbins was
more productive had more yards per rush
and had the same number of touchdowns
better in the passing game than ezekiel
elliott was
and i keep saying to myself okay
either the dallas cowboys went wild with
zeke or the baltimore ravens got one of
the steals of this draft and many other
drafts in jk dobbins give me dobbins
love that pick peter
yeah and you know unlike other teams
where a running back comes in as a
rookie and it puts the veteran on notice
i think mark ingram is going to welcome
the presence of j.k dobbins and it's
going to extend mark ingram's career
and it's going to just diversify that
offense even more and just give it
another weapon it's just another weapon
for an offense that already was chock
full of them i am going to stay with
that same position
and i this was one of those eyebrow
razors for me in round two when the
colts took jonathan taylor that one was
extremely intriguing for me talk about
what it means marlon mack which means
marlon mack see you later after this
season the guy they've sent out the
signals they want to keep i mean
you know jonathan taylor the the most
significant running back the colts have
drafted since edger and james really all
due respect to uh uh who's the guy
dominic rhodes that should have been the
mvp of super bowl 41 but i i think that
jonathan taylor can be great for the
colts he was great for wisconsin my only
concern is does he have too much wear
and tear but uh
you know at a time when you're not sure
what your quarterback is going to be who
it's going to be where you're going to
find him beyond this year having a guy
like taylor makes it easier for the
quarterback to play because i think he's
going to churn up a ton of yards
touchdowns etc for the colts all right
chris you're up
yeah well i like that pick mike and
again you know
you know we we fought we all fall into
this trap me included where we just look
at the bottom line of the stats of a
player and we go oh well he must be
marlon mack ran for a thousand yards he
must have been had a great year it was a
good year it's about what was there to
be had though and i think if you took
like the top five running backs of
football and put them on the
indianapolis colts it would have been 15
1600 yards rushing so i think that's why
they evaluated that and said man
jonathan taylor can get a whole lot out
of a little and we open up a lot of big
holes and imagine what he can do with
that so i like that pick mike i mean i'm
really excited about what he brings all
right i'm gonna go to new england for my
second round pick and specifically the
safety they took out of lenoir-rhyne
that's right lenoir-rhyne which i was
when i first saw film on this guy i was
like where the hell is lenoir-rhyne and
i don't think i wasn't saying it right
either as we know me and pronunciation
they're not real good but
6-1 217 pounds ran a 449 had a 42 inch
vertical
you know he's one of those guys again
it's a a little bit of a tough
evaluation because of the the talent he
is playing at that level of college
football but man when you talk about a
specimen you know i i wrote down mike
and i know you've heard me say this and
peter you might you know i thought this
guy has a chance like his ceiling is
sean taylor-esque type of talent to be
that big and explosive and be able to
turn his hips and not only be good at
open field tackling but in coverage and
then bill belichick where we know he
values those hybrid linebacker safety
type players so much uh i am really
excited to see kyle duggar and what he
can do with the new england patriots and
if he matches up with what i saw in film
and does it translate to the nfl or was
i tricked by the lack of competition
at that level of college football
my next pick i'm going to take a wide
receiver for the denver broncos
who is not named jerry judy
i'm going to take kj hamler the uh the
wide receiver for the broncos who they
pick number 46 overall and the reason
i'm gonna take him is that
he is going to be denver's henry ruggs
and and john elway i think he told me
something on friday night after the
second and third rounds he said you know
when we were studying all the receivers
in this draft because we knew we wanted
to get speed and we're studying the
receiver position and we keep looking at
kj hamler in that 100-yard kick return
he had against michigan in the 2019
season
and he was so much faster than everybody
else that i decided hey let's put our
watches on this guy and let's do a 40
with him and you guys probably remember
one of the stories with the draft kj
hamler did not have a 40 times right
didn't work out at the combine hadn't
run one last year at penn state nobody
knew what he was the 40. and all elway
said he just runs faster than everybody
else right and they did a 40 time in
this hundred yard dash
and it was 3.93 seconds and it's elway's
just laughing and he just says look i
know it's from a running start but he
ran
40 yards in 3.93 seconds
and and that plus the fact he's
tremendously
productive
and elusive as well
kj hamler is going to be the answer for
denver they hope
uh basically the tyree kill
and it's funny that you mention henry
ruggs in the kj hamlet comparison
because henry ruggs is my next one
because henry ruggs doesn't have
cortland sun he doesn't have jerry judy
he doesn't have drew locke henry ruggs
is a man on an island with the raiders
and he's my
picking round too because i keep going
back to that graphic
of all the guys who ran really fast at
the scouting combine at the receiver
position for the last 17 years and and i
it's a milk carton list it's guys who
did nothing in the nfl uh and we're
still waiting to see if john ross is
going to do anything but it's kind of a
kiss of death and when you don't have
help around you
it's all on henry ruggs and he's the
first receiver off the board the
pressure the expectation the fast 40
time i'm very intrigued to see what he
can do for the raiders because the deck
is stacked against him just by virtue of
the circumstance it says nothing about
his talent just the circumstances are
not good for henry ruggs heading into
the nfl all right we're gonna get right
to round three of our draft the most
intriguing draft picks in 2020 chris
sims you're on the clock and it's
ticking loudly
man i'm i'm stuck i'm a little torn in
between here all right i mean there's
there's two guys to make up your mind
you had a whole comment
to make up your mind you know i wanted
to add some flavor here but i'm going
with chase claypool the second round
pick for the pittsburgh steelers all
right that's the guy i'm really i mean
mike you know i've been banging the drum
for this guy i think he was one of the
more talented guys in the whole draft i
think he deserved to be more in the top
receiver conversation you know i'm just
being in person and seeing chase
claypool in person the last three years
this is one of the freakiest specimens
i've ever seen in my life i've said it's
brandon marshall it's vincent jackson
except more explosive you know and i
just look at that mix with him with the
pittsburgh steelers i think he could be
the literally go-to guy number one
dangerous weapon for that offense this
year you know when you're 238 pounds and
you ran a 4-4 flat and a forty and a
half inch vertical and you got a guy
like big ben who could throw the deep
ball as well as he can and then of
course they have other receivers that'll
take a little attention off of him and
we know pittsburgh's a master at you
know drafting wide receivers and having
a keen eye uh eye for for that position
i just look at that and would not be
shocked if chase claypool wasn't the
go-to number one target you know notre
dame he was open a lot last year they
had some issues on offense that led to
him not getting the ball as much as he
should have his stats i think would have
blown people out of the water if he was
hit more when he was wide open down the
field but i'm really fascinated by this
guy
so my third pick is another golden domer
who catches the ball and it's cole
commet when that pick was first made
number 43 by the chicago bears the first
tight end off the board in this draft
i think everybody across america who
knows anything about football said
can the chicago bears please stop
drafting and picking up tight ends
how many do they have and i went and
looked
uh and and at their depth chart they now
have 10
and and obviously they're not all gonna
go to camp or whatever happens during
this season but the reason i really like
this pick is that last year i know
that matt nagy was so
frustrated at the tight end position
because his top three tight ends all
ended up going on ir
and he said to himself this will never
happen again as long as i'm a head coach
and so he's overdone it at tight end
but now in getting cole commed in my
opinion you get a separation guy at
tight end with great hands and a guy who
right away right now you put two he
loves two tight end formations okay
you put jimmy graham and cole comet out
there even if it's like third and 13
instead of going four wide i could see
you going two and two because he loves
how cole comet can catch the ball
in traffic downfield at 6-6 to me
i think cole comet has a really good
chance to be an excellent player in the
nfl and he's going to the right head
coach
all right we're really pinched on time i
don't have a whole lot of of opportunity
to discuss this one but kicker justin
rohrwasser the fifth round pick of the
new england patriots with the
controversial tattoo on his arm of the
three percenter militia group i am
stunned that that if it did get through
the
uh the filter of bill belichick didn't
know about it i'm assuming he knows
about it because he knows about
everything that's been kind of a little
back end controversy that continues to
linger and it's not like the patriots
don't have experience with players who
had controversial tattoos that may or
may not have been evidence in a murder
trial not that it's going to lead that
way with justin rohrwasser obviously but
the idea that that you would even on a
kicker you can find kickers anywhere the
idea that you would roll the dice when
you know you have a built-in controversy
with this guy and it's something that's
not going to go away it's going to
continue to bubble it's going to
continue to percolate and we'll see
where it goes from
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports